well i'd like to tell you that i could
claim success on more than one hand out
of 50 government's i would say in the
long run we probably made some great
success in in Jordan and Egypt and
ironically even in Pakistan and the
energy sector things have fallen apart
since then the problem that I think is
most interesting to say well why don't
government's listen to what even most
officials would say was fundamentally
sound advice the problem is in many of
these countries you know because of the
large volumes of poor people energy
prices are highly subsidized in some
cases free and still in large parts of
Indians India farmers pay nothing for
electricity and so of course because
there's no value on the good demand
shoots to the roof and then the Indian
government can't build enough generation
capacity so it becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy but it's really the political
constraints these countries are under
are very very serious and it's easy for
the I I'm out for the World Bank to come
in and say oh you need to rationalize
prices and you know get them up to the
real cost but you know we don't as we
were talking earlier we don't have our
prices reflecting the cost of carbon so
in some ways we're not that different so
I think that's the biggest thing they
don't see any near-term benefit by
making some of these tough reforms even
though they recognize that they're on a
collision course if they don't do these
things so they do they do them at the
margin try to keep the system intact but
sadly in a place like Pakistan today you
know most of the major cities have
electricity shortage is 16 18 hours a
day and that's true in many large cities
in India around the world in the big
cities electricity is you know often
only available three or four hours a day
if at all and of course as we mentioned
at the start of our talk there's still
huge numbers of people to have no access
to electricity at all so these are the
real dilemmas so it's easy to talk about
western-style reforms creating
regulatory regimes for transparency and
all this but in the final analysis gov
ments generally don't embark on policies
that may well mean their political
demise sooner rather than later